hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to the ed talks live stream
subset of the homeroom uh we have a very
exciting conversation with beth gondales
beth gonzalez assistant superintendent
of detroit public schools so start
thinking of questions for beth and you
can put those in the message board but
before we go into that i'll give my
standard announcement reminder that we
are a not-for-profit we can only exist
through philanthropic donations so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate any donation makes a huge
difference uh there's good analysis
that even one every dollar donated to
khan academy has four to five hundred
dollars of social impact so it's it's
hard to find
anything out there that that gives you
that type of social return so hopefully
think about making those donations
special shout out to
the organizations that stepped up during
uh kovid when they saw that
need for khan academy was even larger
traffic had gone up dramatically to khan
academy uh but we were running higher
costs so special thanks to bank for
america google.org at t fastly and
novartis and many others
for helping us fill that gap but we
still need more help especially we still
have this a multi-million dollar gap
going into 2021 a last but not least
there's a version of this that you can
get in podcast form homeroom with sal
the podcast check that out wherever you
get your podcasts so with that i'm
excited to introduce beth gonzalez
assistant independent of detroit public
schools
beth welcome
hi sal thank you so much so
happy to be here this afternoon
no and we're so happy to have you
you know i you you and other
administrators
yourselves or district leaders around
the country or in the world really have
had a very non-enviable job over the
last uh nine months or so i'd love to
you know more narrative of how detroit
public schools has thought about
uh
learning
as early as last march when when the
schools have to start being closed
physically
through the summer and all the way until
now
great uh yes our roles certainly have
been dynamic
and i have been really fortunate to get
to connect with other leaders and and
like roles like mine and other cities um
and it's been you know it's probably one
of the most least anticipated
um greatest challenges but also a
landscape of opportunity as well
so as we navigate through this we think
really critically about what our
decisions mean for students
and then what does it mean for right now
and what can we how can we use this
opportunity long term as well
um so
in detroit um it's been a really
interesting uh journey so beginning in
the spring obviously like most districts
nationally we
you know without in without any um
warning sort of we closed um and
essentially initially we distributed
packets paper packets to students for a
three week period that led us up into
spring break
and then during that
almost four week timeline my team and
other teams working with actually in our
district about 126 educators and a
number of partner organizations
really launched what we called a
distance learning plan um and that was
where
we shifted from
um
you know
to online instruction right with
pre-recorded lessons we developed over a
thousand of them we leveraged khan
academy content
um and uh daily instruction for a
limited period of time with our
educators using building up on a
platform we had already been using but
not at scale microsoft teams
and what we learned in that time was we
were able to
ensure continuity of learning
we built on the high quality
instructional materials that we had
adopted over the last few years to be
able to continue instruction
aligned to our vision of excellent
instruction
but all of our students did not have
equitable access to that instruction
so some students were watching these
youtube videos on phones participating
in class
through teams on cell phones through
apps
versus actually having a stable computer
and
that is where um in the spring our
superintendent and chief strategy
officer and senior level leaders in the
district really started thinking uh
about how do we go after this complete
you know a huge digital divide in the
city
and just frankly an inequity that still
existed in our system that wasn't
present in other systems
where students were able to just go home
and use computers and so
when
we started leading here in the district
the device race ratio um
was at its best like six to one
making it really difficult to actually
do any at scale digital learning in
classrooms district wide so we had been
doing some really intense work to move
our schools to one to one
and last spring we were in the last
deployments of our high school
but
you know
really what our students needed was
devices in their homes
and so we were very thankful
in working with the philanthropic
community
um to receive a 23 million dollar
investment for an initiative that we
call connected futures
and through that and through summer we
deployed about 44 000 you know over 44
000 devices um to the students uh in our
district which um we sit just above 50
000 students
um and so
you know through the summer as we
reached fall
we really worked on
closing the digital divide in terms of
access devices however
that did not mean that all families and
students were
well equipped to use that device to
learn on a daily basis and so
while we celebrated that opportunity
we've we've faced um a number of
challenges um even after students had
access and and the district actually
made about a four million dollar
investment
and students having access to uh
internet connectivity in their homes
and that's a commitment that we'll
continue so
we've just really been we're constantly
reflecting on what we've been able to
accomplish where we are what are the
challenges our students and families are
still facing um because despite having
done that work and you know there's a
lot of cities nationally who have liked
stories um
and i think that's you know that that in
itself is progress but we still have
students that aren't able to participate
in school on a daily basis
um and we're you know we've launched a
number of things to address that but
certainly have still
more room to grow
um
and so i would describe that uh
overarchingly as sort of like what's
happened in detroit um and for me you
know one of the things i in my role as
assistant superintendent for curriculum
instruction you know teaching and
learning is at the core the heart of
what i do um and so
we have been really really
focused on making sure that our students
have continued access and our teachers
have continued access to high quality
instructional materials um that are
highly rated that are um
you know
part of our work and that's part of what
we're really still pursuing um is
culturally relevant materials
um and so that's a point of pride but
there are still nuances like there's
multiple platforms and that's hard for
kids and hard for families so
even as i share celebrations um each of
those those um accomplishments are
coupled with
um things that we're still working on to
improve um what we're doing for our
students
and you know there's there's a lot in
that and once again thank you for the
heroic effort that you and your fellow
district leaders have been doing
you know i'm curious about that
percentage of kids that or whatever the
percentage is that that haven't been
able to engage you know how large has
that been we've been hearing that from a
lot of districts you know i live in a
middle income upper middle income
suburban small school district a school
teacher shares the cul-de-sac with me
she was telling me that 5-10 of her kids
haven't been engaged i could imagine the
problem could be worse in detroit how
big is the problem there and what are
the best explanations for why these kids
haven't been able to engage in what are
you all trying uh to keep them engaged
yeah great question um you know we've
really been looking at uh student
engagement and attendance from a number
of different
uh perspectives um we you know our
enrollment actually as a district has
continued to increase
um and we were making really significant
progress on uh both reducing the number
of chronically absent students
increasing enrollment and increasing
just healthy daily attendance rates
district-wide with some exemplar schools
but the pandemic has really
impacted and our data looks similar to
what it did about two years ago
um students are you know students are
it's not consistent as
you know we don't have students who are
we do have some students who are not
coming at all but
it's inconsistent in terms of period of
the day or day of the week
um and the way that we're really so
we're thinking about that in two ways
the first um is really intentional
outreach um and so our we've leveraged
all school staff
um to reach out to families to do well
checks to offer
um supports beyond um just academic
support so we're thinking about the
mental health of the family or what
additional needs they they may have
that is food insecurity or utility
assistance um in our school culture
facilitators and our deans and our
school staff it's all hands on deck
trying to reach out to families to
understand why their students may not be
participating
beyond that
we have a team of district team members
who led a large effort including
district volunteers
and others to canvas and to really go to
every home
for our students who haven't
showed up um and you know that was work
i actually did myself in our
neighborhoods meeting families and
talking to them face to face of course
outside socially distance safely with
masks on
about what challenges they're facing
um and communicating with them to make
sure they understand their child does
have a device
their school's waiting for them
and we're eager to provide instruction
and supports to their family
we now are at a place where it is really
about home visits and outreach um and so
despite the increased infection rates in
the city and the challenges in terms of
being face to face
um we're
we're trying uh to engage students as
must as possible and we're also studying
the impact on their performance so this
is a national conversation that's
emerged i know another a number of other
school districts are grappling with this
but we have studied and we know that
district wide when we look at quarter
one performance of our students in 2019
versus quarter one performance of our
students in 2020 we have about a 15
increase in f grades district-wide and
there is a variance across schools um
with you know
actually decreases um and some of our
particularly in some of our lower grades
and also increases in some of our high
schools where we're seeing larger total
numbers of students with f's and so
that's really pushing us to think about
student engagement in a couple different
ways right like how do we support kids
to make sure they're coming and then
when they're coming how do we support
them to be successful in this completely
new learning environment
when you did some of these home visits
what did people tell you why their kids
weren't showing up to the you know the
the microsoft uh teams uh classroom what
were the explanations you've been
hearing
yeah um there are a number of reasons um
which are very legitimate so
um you know some families faced
challenges with the device they
originally received have having already
been
broken um and not feeling like they had
a resources or a solution
in order to have that fixed
and in order to address that actually
the district recently launched 13
regional hubs throughout the city
where we're providing a number of
in-person supports to families including
actually uh device repair online
learning support
um mental health resources actually we
are offering covent testing
um
to support families and so
to help make that not be continue to be
an issue
in the early stages of this work um when
i was out in neighborhoods
in some ways uh families just didn't
feel like they
had the
all of the clear communication and
information about what was available to
them what they were supposed to do how
they were to participate
um and so that's why the home visits
were so important because it really
helped us face to face describe to
someone what to do get their cell phone
number
and just solve the problem alongside of
them
we also have we also launched an online
learning help hotline we've had over 000
calls to date um
there so that families can continue to
call in and say
gosh i need help this isn't working i
don't know what to do how do i enroll
now that you know so much is so
different
um so those are a few of the reasons
that families shared with us and and
some of the things that we've done
to try to support them and address that
so it sounds like it's you know in some
categories just tech difficulties
and then probably a little bit of an
activation energy of just not knowing
how to engage in this in this new
this new world on the other issue you
mentioned the the students failing
disproportionately especially at the
high school level how do y'all
categorize that how much of that is the
access issue we just talked about how
much of that is uh kind of stress and
mental health and anxiety and depression
and how much of that is just something
something else
yeah
so we're actually studying the
relationship right now um between
student performance and attendance to
see
um you know what the
relationship is there
we've also
been actively engaging in focus groups
with our students to hear from them you
know
what their perceptions are about this
challenge what ideas they have how they
feel
um we've heard a number of things you
know from from students themselves
um
students have articulated that
you know this is hard on them and it's
hard on their teachers
that um
they sometimes are challenged by the
number of platforms and what's required
of them to submit assignments they
talked about examples where they had
submitted work but their teacher didn't
receive it
um they talked about the expectation for
submission of work feeling as though
you know we're not in school we're at
home we're online
um but my teacher's expectation for
turning things in on the on time hasn't
really changed and it's really not
um sensitive to where i am in terms of
having to provide care for a younger
sibling
or um
having to
you know be a caregiver in my own home
or or having other responsibilities
um so i think students are facing a
number of things we also heard about
from kids just like you said sal where
you know they're really their mental
health is
is suffering they feel isolated they
feel alone
um
they say you know i wake up in the
morning it's dark i get on my computer i
finish school it's dark
um and
you know what i don't have the same
social engagement
so um you know one thing i didn't speak
to earlier was
our district was actually one of the
first school districts now i think it
was the first school district nationally
certainly large urban um to welcome
students back for in-person instruction
after the spring closure so we started
preparing and launched in-person
instruction in summer um
and had only like three cases
in our schools at that time
and then opened the school year with
three different sort of implementations
one was an in-person opportunity for
learning matching teachers who were
willing to teach in person with students
who wanted to learn in person or whose
families wanted them to learn in person
we also launched learning centers so
these students were learning online but
were able to come to an educational
environment with the support of other
educators like dean school culture
facilitators assistant principals para
educators academic interventionists to
make sure that they have the support
they needed for the assignment
submission and the online participation
and then we also
uh had you know almost 80 percent of our
students participating just online
but unfortunately because of um
increases in infection rates um at the
very end of november we had to shift to
just online learning again and so
these these challenges that some of our
high school students are facing are
actually increasing um not decreasing
with their siblings not being able to go
to learning centers um and learning and
them if they benefited from it learning
in person so
lots of that's why we're talking to them
to learn from them about the challenges
they're facing um and to move to
strategies that make sense uh for a
pathway to success um including
supporting our own educators and
guidance on equitable grading practices
for example
i mean on that last piece this is
something you know we've always talked
about academic pre-pandemic the social
mastery learning that
if you get a c or a b or an f that you
should always have an opportunity to
uh remediate and and get it to an a
level
especially during covert this seems
important because we all know what it
does to a student's self-esteem and
frankly if they have a gap in something
they should be able to fill it in
otherwise they'll have trouble with more
advanced topics do you see uh
mechanisms by which y'all can these kids
who are failing or getting worse grades
than you normally would to be able to do
makeup work so to speak to maybe improve
their grades so it doesn't have a
lasting implication for their for their
life
yeah in fact what you're describing is
something i'm really personally
passionate about i was a math educator
and um so much of our work leading up
into this pandemic
you know with this with the current
student performance in the district you
know we have a number of students
already um who would be considered one
or more years behind
and so a really a huge part of our work
is providing tiered interventions to
those students and making sure that they
have the academic time and space to do
that work beyond just continuing with
high quality grade level instruction
um and so
you know we do have a foundation around
what you specifically spoke to which is
course recovery
we
we've done work over the last couple
years to have strong course recovery
structures in place
had um you know over the last summer we
had students recover about 600 courses
um and you know that's something that
will will build upon
as we move forward i think our job right
now given where we are in the school
year is to think about and enact
strategies to prevent some of that with
our educators so that that work can be
done before
students find themselves
in that space
and so not only are we doing work for
success with grade level instruction but
we're also actually expanding and
pursuing you know with this unique
structure with differentiated schedules
with things being online there are
actually also opportunities um to
provide direct services and
interventions to students in a way that
um
you know we can do in person but the
online structures have some value so
in fact in our high school we have
students um
who really need reading interventions i
mean i i realize at that point you know
most students are you know using reading
as a tool to learn and achieve in their
core courses but we've made a deep
commitment to addressing students
learning gaps so
uh we're launching and we've done work
um
our district-wide in fact our goal is to
reach over 9 000 students in tier 3
reading interventions um using this
opportunity and being able to flexibly
group them right because they're not in
a brick and mortar building in one space
they can only come together at one time
we can actually
pull across schools and cross classrooms
uh to do some deep interventions whether
those be one-on-one or three-on-one so
this is all work that uh we have
underway we're pursuing and we just hope
to expand um and to your point to
continue to leverage um the resources
you know like khan academy and math to
help support that
yeah no the dream scenario is the
students should show mastery on khan
academy that y'all give them you know
give them give them credit but we could
talk about that offline you know there's
a question related to this from on uh
youtube nish 786
and there's actually three questions in
here each of which are pretty big but
so does
they're asking does online school work
well for both teachers and students and
maybe you know we've talked a little bit
about where it's not working so well for
students i am curious about the teacher
side of things what are what are you
hearing from teachers about what's
not working for them or are there
certain things that are working well for
them
yeah great question
i
um i think if i answered that with a
broad you know stroke a yes or no
i would not be attending to the nuance
here uh because obviously
um our teaching force like other
teachers actually were a diverse set of
of educators um with lots of different
experiences and perspectives
and so um you know
the things that i've heard from
educators
that
are working well
one is you know obviously we are in a
pandemic
and so
you know there are a number of educators
who have clearly expressed their
concerns about teaching in person and so
i think the opportunity um
to teach students online um is
is educators are thankful for that
opportunity for their their own safety
um
but i will say uh we also have had a
strong group of educators teach in
person and we've invested in
a significant amount of ppe and and
resources to help
make those safe environments for
educators and students
teachers you know feel
have said you know they feel supported
by us so we adopted a learning
management system called schoology
we ensured um that we
you know procured and provided to
educators all of the online options for
their existing programs so we didn't
force them to learn something completely
new just to do it online we really
transitioned their existing
content
to a digital platform we also
complemented the use of schoology with
teams
and have made iterative improvements
there for teachers to deliver
instruction and we really put our
teachers at the center
meaning them delivering instruction each
day to students we think is a real
priority in our implementation
i think teachers you know have grown
themselves in their digital literacies
and capacities and they actually see
growth in kids and especially our our
teachers who are serving our youngest
students
it's really fun to talk to them about
the things kids have done on computers
and online online platforms
where they've had success that they
didn't um anticipate
and teachers still feel deeply connected
to their students so outside of using a
computer they
they are you know connecting with them
um you know i talk to teachers who
go to their students homes to bring them
things
and work to make them successful so i
think educators still feel equivalently
committed to their own students
students are also some you know it
varies uh different kids have different
supports different prior experiences
um
and so there are strong examples of
students who learned new 21st century
skills
that they didn't previously have we
really have uh we're a microsoft
district so we've leveraged like um
class notebook
uh microsoft whiteboard
um and a number of other i'm not coming
up with all the platforms but we've you
know our kids have learned to use these
things and honestly they're things as a
professional i use also
um and i think some of our students have
enjoyed a little bit
of autonomy
um and so
you know i i will say there are positive
things that will have long-term
implications for what in-person learning
looks like um because i think kids will
find just writing a notebook paper
potentially archaic
now that they have their own device so
um and there are still there are
struggles uh for educators and for
teachers in this but we actually as
educators i'm really glad that question
was asked because we do need you know
we're so focused on like what do we got
to do better but we do need to also
reflect on what kinds of things have
have benefited students and i'll name
one last thing as a benefit and that is
uh expanded equitable access so we've
actually been able to expand students
access to dual enrollment in the
district with our university partners
because it wasn't happening in person so
we weren't limited to just one school so
we have students participating across
schools
and so we've been able to serve more
students
and so i think that also has
implications district-wide for when we
return you know how do we make sure
every student in the district who wants
to take
calc 3
can
uh with a university professor
no that's great well
you know these conversations always go
by faster than i expect uh you know
thank you so much uh for joining us and
you know frankly thank you for the work
that you and all the other educators not
just in detroit but around the world are
doing right now to keep kids learning uh
but it shows that you know y'all are
doing
i would say better than than what what
we could hope for given how strains and
circumstances are and i you know there's
a lot to worry about uh with these kids
who seem to be kind of falling off and
failing or not engaged but there's some
there's many things to be hopeful for
and it's because of your tireless effort
so thank you for that
oh thank you so i
i get to say these things but i
certainly do not do them alone um and
and
you know our superintendent's leadership
through this time and actually our
school board's leadership during this
time like everyone in our organization
is deeply focused
on students putting students first
and you know we're committed to continue
to problem solve with the community
and elevate solutions
to improve what they're experiencing now
and support them in the years to come so
thank you so much for having me
um
and
i appreciate it
thanks for joining us
well thank you everyone for joining this
conversation uh hope hope uh you you got
as much out of that as i did obviously
there's a lot of things to be worried
about uh because of covid and you know
some of these were trends that were
going on even before covent and they've
just gotten worse with you know kids
gaps etc
but you know there's some really good
leadership out there in the country and
the world that is uh making some efforts
and i think thinking about things in
really interesting ways so thanks for
joining this week uh this was the last
homeroom for for this week and we might
take a little bit of a hiatus for the
holidays so
depending but it might be the new year
before we see each other again so happy
uh holidays
see you later
you